Reescribe la siguiente expresión como un producto de exponentes positivos,
posteriormente evalúa la expresión cuando "x" es igual a 2, hagamos la primera parte.
Quieren que escribamos la expresión como un producto de exponentes positivos,
no quieren que aparezca este exponente - 3, ni este exponente de 5 a la - 2,
quieren que reescribamos eso con exponentes positivos,
y para hacer eso hay que recordar que algo elevado a la potencia negativa,
déjame escribirlo por aquí, sí tenemos...
digamos..
"x"
elevado a la -2
esto es igual a 1
sobre "x" cuadrada,
y en general si tenemos "a"
elevado a la - "b"
esto es igual a 1 sobre "a"
elevado a la "b".
Podemos eliminar ese exponente negativo,
si lo escribimos como 1 entre el número elevado a la potencia positiva, a la - "b" es el recíprocode "a" a la "b",
apliquemos entonces eso por acá, "x" elevado a la potencia -3...
déjame hacer esto con distintos colores
"x" elevado a la - 3 es exactamente lo mismo que
1 sobre "x" al cubo,
eso por definición.
Luego tenemos...
multiplicado por 5 elevado a la potencia -2,
aquí hacemos lo mismo
5 elevado a la potencia - 2,
eso es igual a 1 sobre 5 al cuadrado,
y finalmente tenemos que multiplicar por "x" cuadrada, no hay que hacer nada por que el exponente es positivo,
así es que esto multiplicado por "x" cuadrada.
Ya hemos hecho lo primero, ya escribimos la expresión con un producto de exponentes positivos,
ahora evaluemos la expresión
cuando "x" es igual a 2.
Así es que donde veamos una "x" vamos a sustituir un 2, esto va a ser igual a 1 entre...
déjame hacerlo en el mismo color...
esto es igual a 1 entre 2 al cubo
que multiplica a 1
entre 5 al cuadrado y que multiplica a la vez,
a 2 al cuadrado.
Ya hemos sustituido el valor de "x" igual a 2, y vamos ahora a desarrollar las potencias,
2 al cubo hagámoslo por aquí.
2 al cubo es 2 por 2 por 2 y esto es igual a 8.
Así es que este primer término es 1/8 que multiplica a 1 sobre 5 al cuadrado,
5 al cuadrado es igual, 5 por 5
y esto es igual a 25.
1 sobre 25 que multiplica a
2 al cuadrado, 2 al cuadrado es...
vamos a hacerlo también por este lado...
2 al cuadrado, esto es igual a 2 por 2
y esto es igual a 4.
Así es que esto es por 4,
este 4 lo podemos escribir como 4 sobre 1.
Hagamos ahora el producto de estas fracciones.
Primero multiplicamos los numeradores
1 por 1 por 4 es igual a 4
dividido entre el producto de los denominadores,
esto es 8 por 25, esto es 4 por 25 es igual a 100,
esto es igual a 200.
Muy bien vamos a simplificar 4 entre 200, vamos a tomar cuarta arriba y cuarta abajo, cuarta arriba es 1,
cuarta abajo es 50,
esto es igual a 1 sobre 50.
Y para que lo tomes en cuenta,
hay una manera de simplificar esta expresión, antes de llegar a esta última etapa. Podríamos haber simplificado en esta etapa de aquí.
Si tú...
Déjame reescribir esto...
En este producto,
este término 2 al cuadrado,
lo podemos escribir como 2 al cuadrado entre 1,
el numerador entonces lo podíamos escribir como
1 por 1 por 2 al cuadrado.
Esto es igual entonces a 1 por 1 por 2 al cuadrado,
2 al cuadrado es 2 por 2, así es que esto sería 2 por 2,
no incluimos el producto de 1 por 1, pues el producto 1 por 1 es 1, lo cual no afecta este valor.
¿Qué tenemos en denominador?
En el denominador tenemos 2 por 2 por 2,
eso es 2 al cubo...
que multiplica a...
que multiplica a
5 por 5 que es 5 al cuadrado,
y eso multiplicado por 1, que no modifica este valor,
y aquí ya tenemos varias simplificaciones obvias.
Tenemos aquí un 2 del numerador, con un 2 del denominador, aquí tenemos otro 2 con otro 2,
y al final de cuentas nos resulta 1 sobre
1 dividido entre 2 por
5 por 5
2 por 5 por 5
y esto es igual a lo que tenemos abajo.
Aquí tenemos 2 por 5 = 10 por 5 = 50,
es 1 entre 50,
que ya habíamos obtenido previamente.